I didn't appreciate the little mouth
noise I just heard before screams came
up I think so cuz it wasn't me
I can't we have an eavesdropper whatever
my headphones allow me to hear you and
the game but I can't hear myself I mean
I can hear myself mm-hmm but I can't
hear myself and my headphones should
change your lower third to Mary excuses
that was terrible okay and you are Mikey
McGillicuddy and this is episode two of
our resident evil 2 playthrough this is
not a - yeah we're we calling it
Resident Evil Resident can evil to
remake me so - that makes sense is that
actually you're gonna title it probably
season 9 I think yeah what do we get 10
I think Veronica 9 was 0 I honestly came
I think I've played 10 games oh no no
this is 11 because the revelation is 10
yeah this is 11 this is 11 so we've
played a lot right we've made a couple
updates from the last time cuz we're
kind of actively making some fixes while
we're playing this is our first time
doing these things on skype so Mike
you've got a mic now so you should sound
a lot better you already sound so much
better to me so that was awesome mm-hmm
I got an audio splitter so I can
actually hear the PlayStation coming out
of the PlayStation and you in my
headphones finally sweet yeah dumb voice
isn't competing with yeah you will sorry
your game boy I had to keep the game
really low so I would hear it on my mic
but now I can like really hear the game
so I think it should make it scarier
obviously so I think this will be okay
before we get started I just wanted to
quickly show you some fan art we got it
now we already have seen we you tweeted
this just in case anyone who hasn't seen
it I thought it was so good
yeah me and my mic jacks deltoids
dude that's clearly when I fixated on
it's so good I absolutely love it
sage sage II eighties he likes sent this
in and I love if you look behind it
let me see if I can keep her no it isn't
my dress but like this was like the
original sketch which is so good mm-hmm
and then this is the final product so I
thought that was really cool
yeah my line from Tropic Thunder that I
use a lot now did you check yeah these
things stars I hate that guy I hate him
uh yes so how much do you know about the
remainder of Resident Evil 2 remake what
do you mean like the rest that I have to
play because I had like we barely
started right no I mean never mind I
don't want spoil I think something
something was already brought up on this
episode that is alluding to something
that will happen later the game never
mind it's your relevant I I don't know
the answer is I've been really
particular with spoilers in fact I'm
muting anyone who puts a spoiler in
Twitter until after we beat the game
because I don't want to act like it's
well I already almost did cuz I saw like
a boss that I I think looks different
but anyway I like don't want to we're
gonna harp on it I'm just gonna say I'm
being particular and I don't want to get
spoiled
um okay cool all right so I'm gonna go
back to story so since the last time we
recorded I have played two more
campaigns in this game oh my god yes I
did I did a B scenario and then in a
scenario with the other character you
really are the guy then because I is so
much more than any - alright continue
there's so so much in this game that not
only it's just been a while since we
played it so I've like lost a little bit
of the refresher mm-hmm but I don't know
like I haven't played I haven't seen any
of the new one besides the demo which I
already think we've gotten to the point
that I was at at the demo
so at this point yeah almost completely
fresh from my friend I also wasn't
writing very well Claire is hurt
let me hit was it triangle I forget how
to pull up my right inventory yeah it's
trying so it's triangle so I'm already
on caution because I did get um I got
hit but I have a full heal here so I'm
gonna try and you know get as far as I
can before I have to use that full heal
I did take the photo and look at it um
or what it said what it showed no I can
look it's not sue no it's it's a puzzle
for later on but I'll let you know when
it's necessary okay you can look at it
just to refresh if you want how do I do
it or is it my inventory now yeah you go
inventory and then lry yeah yeah that's
it right there okay so it's a
King religious man holding a scepter and
a book in a book yeah
again it's not super relevant right now
got it so what was your objective let me
see your inventory again trying to I
don't have a lot here I got a gun with
five bullets oh no I got one more
I got a nice yeah you have that's okay
it's not halfway dead yet you have a
decent mount of ammo I think you want to
go stairs if you check the roll of film
well you have your map to your map will
show you like this this game's map is
pretty good about showing you what items
you kind of write also I did put a
couple things away I have a key which is
I no longer need a lion gunpowder and
from so let's check the map II oh I
dodged a zombies to get in this room
yeah so there's zombies outside that I
have to deal with all right have you
have you used they see that item just
north of the dark room have you used
that item yet again I don't spoil it I
can't remember the board's no you told
me that I could put them on the windows
oh yeah these from coming in yes a
hallway that you'll be like backtracking
through pretty often it's a cool
strategy that this game added where you
can actually like stop zombies from
coming in so actually I would say yeah
the window right to left his stairs
actually could be a problem later on so
I wouldn't forward it up and possible
and then you probably just want to go
upstairs okay well there's zombies in
that room so the first thing I have to
do is kill those zombies then put the
boards up is that what we're doing just
so that were yes that make sense doesn't
the lockers here to left if you haven't
opened them have stuff in them
hotdogs come in
what is that do you hear that noise I
don't know if my gameplay is loud enough
no I don't you hear him okay well they
wait Oh is there a zombie near you
there's death there's absolutely without
a [ __ ] doubt there's the zombie on
the other side of the door because I can
hear him go oh yeah this so this there's
usually like a couple in this hallway is
hallway can I choose that oh wait no
actually yeah so it's outside if you can
get the board more at the window quick
enough it won't come through okay
so go try to board up the window
although just keep in mind the zombie
might crash through the window and then
come on board just go up to the window
press X yeah there you go he's right
there in the freeze-frame okay
I got me a trophy thank you
actually okay before you go upstairs
just to cover our bases it looks like
there were some items you did not get
downstairs yet on your mommy to go back
yeah I'd say so just as a refresher the
rooms on your map that are red still
mean that you have not gotten all the
items correct but there's aam be in
there I think it's like well there's
also the room to the Wonder the under
operations room that you haven't tried
yet which might be worth checking out
okay so maybe that first yeah that might
be a lock door but you might as well
check it just so like just before you go
upstairs so this window from now on will
not be able no you just reach his hand
through it's still there oh yeah so this
is that weapons locker with the the
keypad but the safety deposit room I
can't get in here yeah you can that's
the room I was just talking about what
that keypad and everything oh so I've
already been in here so so there's
nothing else for me to do right now in
here you find those keys yeah yeah yeah
I got I think
I'm confused I gotta get out of these
things that I could yeah cuz the two and
the three keys are missing so you need
to find spare keys before you can get
that stuff correct and that's yeah
alright so I'm caught up in here so
where else do you want me to go that the
door to the west I don't know if it's
the office no no no - just like though
under the room under it might be locked
but you might as well check that's your
right it's totally locked I think
actually now that I think of it but it's
worth at least no no no dear right now
okay
oh I think it's yeah okay well now at
least it'll show up this lock check them
out
um okay so now go upstairs or is there
more for me to do here
this hallways red - yeah what am I
missing in a hallway maybe yeah maybe
down here or straight straight that way
yes straight ahead now
god oh you know yeah I think it might be
on that zombies body the item yes dad
you could poke him to check I think it
looks like he was about to push up I
know yeah yes I don't know you'll find
that zombies in this game are rarely
dead [ __ ] alright he had five bullets
on him okay cool so I got five bullets
that was worth it and now this room is
blue okay so should I go into the West
office or should I go upstairs so the
West office is where you did that first
name acronym puzzle at Leon's desk and
you got the six-shooter upgrade yeah so
I think I think you've cleared out
everything you could do now because
there's also that safe in there the dial
say if I don't think you could do
anything until later going upstairs then
there's that guy yeah I knew that was
gonna happen it's still scary
I hate that oh well what is it what's
that noise do you hear it hi oh that was
a critical hit I think I think it's if
you blew his head up good
Oh God I heard him but I liked her
couldn't see him the UM light is so very
specific in this game I knew it watch I
[ __ ] knew it
yeah I agree
oh you hear her arm break I did
hey oh my god they have momentum coming
down the stairs okay she still could be
alive and crawl like yeah so I don't
know if you've encountered this yes in
this game but if just because you down
them twice does not mean they're dead
cause game is even those normals pretty
resilient well I hope they like give me
more knives because I am gonna burn
through knives what's that noise yeah
you'll get more is this person dead yeah
you blew his head up
that was what I like there was a
critical hit our crimson heads a thing
no but like so that was one thing people
were disappointed they took out but like
because they made normal zombies that
much more resilient I think it balances
out okay alright so should I keep going
up the stairs or should I check out the
things down here first check this floor
out there's no zombies no zombies on all
these just steam yeah right that's how
they get you
good things never happen in bathrooms in
horror games a portable safe okay yes so
this is a new puzzle it's pretty
self-explanatory but it might take you a
bit press a button to light up its
corresponding lamp light them all to
open the safe the buttons must be
pressed in a certain order pressing a
single button out of order will cause
all the lights to go out and you will
need to start it over okay so it's a
memory thing and you can do them in any
you can start anywhere as long as you do
them all in order it'll open so you'll
get the gist of it but sometimes I could
take a while because it's like it's
memory based okay all right so so you
can start with that one as long as the
one to the right of that is the next one
you get but that doesn't necessarily
mean that it's gonna be the one to the
right of the button yeah so different
buttons correspond to different lights
and they have to right yeah they'd have
to go in clockwise or counter clockwise
counter clockwise cuz that's the way the
arrows yeah okay okay okay okay yeah so
now you could do the one above that yeah
yeah that was I'll I'll remember the
order I'll try to yeah balls [ __ ] I
damnit alright we've touched the ball
oh so it's yeah the bottom yeah yeah
this one [ __ ] yes I need your hand I
think I think the top one in this column
oh yeah even from across the world you
can help me with puzzles okay wait so
now you can get a few more items out of
that weapons Locker if you want because
that's a although I don't think this
game understands how keyboards work
because you don't necessarily need the
key to press it down but whatever all
right no I like broken I type in a
broken keyboard for like read manga did
you yeah is it cuz you couldn't afford
like a better keyboard yeah I also wore
shopping bags for pants oh my god green
ads I'm almost full so this is just
something to think about
I don't know that you'll find out you
[ __ ] that one got me really good when
I was playing is he alive
oh yeah he doesn't look alive he I mean
you might want to poke him but every
single time I've played he's so just
because that didn't okay that's crazy I
whatever at least you checked oh that
reminds me of the original game where
the first door ever in the series that
wasn't safe remember the door loading
screens when the zombies poured through
here that just making me unsafe yeah I
still feel like I should shoot him again
but I would leave it I mean if you'd
knife to man shot him in the head and he
didn't react he might be alive later on
but he seems docile alright so I assume
that I cannot go into that Steam right
yeah don't try that based on Steam nice
alright so I'm gonna leave yes get
everything in this hallway I don't know
um did you go behind you all the way
like I passed the bathroom door oh I
didn't go and I just started at the
bathroom door there might be something
down the hall there's a plant nice
alright I'm officially full should I
safe rooms right underneath you might as
well go deposit a few things you could
you should actually just use that spare
key to get the items it's right down the
hall no yeah that that keyboard key that
you just got you might as well install
that so you can sir is there a um oh
Lord oh Jesus I don't like that man
okay sorry what
so you can actually okay so if you
combine these two normal gunpowder's
you'll get handgun ammo but wait I would
wait because if you get high-grade you
can make her nade so you might as well
and you're already pretty flush with
handgun rounds alright okay
I'm gonna go to that yeah
so I mean either I would look around
first to see whether you want to use the
two or three key
I think the there's also the ones on the
other side too so - we'll get you
gunpowder and grenade rounds right now
you can't get that until you have both
keys anyway so you'll get more if you do
- right I'm not gonna use a grenade
thingy anyway I don't even have a
grenade launcher oh yeah I guess I could
just throw the grenade no it's I don't
want spoil anything uh I don't know like
just do whatever you want um I guess
what do you wanna there knife would be
nice okay you do have a lot of gunpowder
already
yeah so the knife is 103 that way that
way if my knife does in fact run out I
can just get it is it 108 was the other
one
or I think you already did that
the other one was 208 I thought there
was another one there were 203 as well
which she can get yet alright so I could
do 208 should I do that no you can't you
need the two key first you can put the
three key all right I'm done all right
I'm ready
and then I'd probably just go all the
way up the stairs now okay mr. dicks
gonna annoy you I'm sure
I know [ __ ] you need a name for him
dungus all right there you go
oh yeah drunkest hello the windows
brought it up your strongest
ooh what was that dark and stormy night
god I just realized I'm really unhealthy
as well like yeah you have a full heal
your son
makes me nervous that song I see him I
see his [ __ ] head I see it where is
it where is it I see him is this a
statue
that's it [ __ ] it's just Capcom being
dicks that is so rude they like a
hundred percent got me
yeah there we go my first Keith I hate
that nothing I want to stab it good
probably damn it nope my knife integrity
is there nothing in here thought there'd
be like a book but who reads anymore um
what I'm just sorry I'm thinking out
thinking through where this Spade doors
are
I'm [ __ ] so early what is it what is
that it's so early for me be freaking
out like this you're going through hell
keep going not just kidding actually I'd
back up to I'm joking I don't know what
it was oh it sounds like a dog you hate
dogs
I hate dogs in the zombie bugs zombie
dogs because they're hard to kill and I
don't like killing dogs and they make
they like him you know they like making
noises [ __ ] wait there's a note at the
end of the hallway first sorry I want to
make sure you see that note
- any survivors consider this a gift for
anyone still fortunate to me and alive
keep your eyes peeled for those creepy
[ __ ] that look like they were skinned
alive lickers we call them they are
blind as bats but they're hearing more
than makes up for that so long as you
don't run around like a total idiot guns
a-blazing you should be able to slip by
them so long as you don't run around
Knievel style guns blazing cuz liquors
were never about ball stealthy before
yeah if you see a liquor it so if
they're yeah well we'll cross that
bridge when we come to it I just wanted
you to see this note because it's a
pretty good foreshadowing thing either
way make like my grandma and creep
around as slow as possible yeah
grandma is that you jeez um so I need to
know how to crawl or walk it's just like
is it just walk I think you can even
walk in normal speed just don't run or
shoot or touch them do not touch them
yeah just be stealthy okay yeah sure the
liquors in this game alright
can they hear that did they hear that
you don't know for sure there's a liquor
around right now I know what am i what
do I want I just want to get out of here
like at all is your inventory almost
full yeah it's gonna be full with these
boards no I'm not hold on let me see let
me see it again
II I would leave those for now you'll be
back there here yeah I do like the being
able to board up windows though I'm
gonna go so [ __ ] slow
is that a door should I go in there yeah
um check out the rest of this room first
okay
oh god is that a thing weird fungus well
they did such a good job scaring the
[ __ ] out of me
that's why I wanted you to read the note
first but I feel like I did more harm
than good because I'm being so quiet all
right I mean do it do whatever you're
gonna take this yeah yeah that's oh [ __ ]
yeah that's huge that's two more slots
oh good now I can take the thingy
yeah actually I'd still hold off on the
boards there might be a yeah yeah
actually never mind let me read this
some guys scribbling damn these
corporate [ __ ]
they cut me off after all I've done for
them but that's how it's gonna be so so
be it
I'm gonna have a little fun of my own as
the world goes to [ __ ] I boarded all
these filthy pigs in a steel pen and got
some c4 all I gotta do is detonate it
and sayonara suckers it's no fun if it's
over too soon so maybe I'll give that
raving loon something really squeal
about I'll give him a little toy and
tell him kill the guy next to you and
I'll spare the others wonder what I'll
do you yell about justice and pride but
how many times did you go against me
your own superior such a good cop so
good you had to die man this is fun I
need some music mm-hmm I all this guy's
a nut so so yeah the sea forests this is
the cage II was talking about doesn't
look like the sea floor went off no it
didn't that's what he yeah is that the
thingy I want just got a walk
really [ __ ] slowly okay oh I got to
use a knife on it correct No
you don't have what you need yet it's
but remember that that's there I can't
take this no because based on what he
said like you you want the Seaforth to
get into that cell that you just saw you
just need something to detonate it with
oh god is it in the [ __ ] ceiling oh
great more bullets
I know you meant that sincerely but it
sounded so sarcastic I don't know I
meant it sarcastically just cuz you have
so many already I don't want to walk on
this isn't this gonna make noise sir
I'm so like you you would know if there
was a liquor like in your vicinity real
loud they couldn't tell because the game
is scary
yeah I just go through here this is
gonna be like a 14 hour playthrough now
you're so okay for the sake sake of
there's no liquor yet no you're fine
alright I'm gonna kill this guy I
remember this [ __ ] hallway
I remember this hallway like it was
yesterday
what do you remember I remember the
what's that noise
I remember the fixed camera angles and
being on one end of the staircase and
then eventually finding the other got
you idiot
got you again why is his neck so long
who she's dead
gross oh this is is this a jump thing no
way
no you just go around the other end for
now because there's this staircase I
don't want to use that right hmm so the
door to your left are up and to your
left that goes straight back to Marvin
that's the Great Hall this this one that
I'm looking at that my character is
looking at I know you can't see where
I'm pointing anymore that person the one
behind you yeah she's dead I just you
that's why I asked what you remembered
from this room cuz that's that happening
this episode was going entirely too well
you're an [ __ ] I don't think they can
climb ladders like normal zombies cannot
I'll help you there dad there is a stair
it was bad person I don't believe
anything that you say holy [ __ ] that was
awful you're terrible but yeah that's
one of those scares like even if you
know it's coming it's still so loud that
you're right like a thousand percent I
forgot so I already shot that guy so I
should probably finish it right um who'd
you shoot oh wait this should
Oh what should I do about that guy he's
coming hey mean you don't you have
enough bullets where you're probably
finally he's coming I will say you'll be
back through here several nice you're
getting pretty lucky with those critical
hits
that's raw skill okay oh look at half
his face is on the handrail still of
this area sir hey Jeff what's your
[ __ ] deck that Jeff [ __ ] face all
right so this guy might be alive yeah is
he knocked his hat off scalped he's no
officer of the law
Oh another and I am
that's might as well um okay so would
that cop you have not checked thought I
smelled bacon okay
how the [ __ ] do I get out of here
oh that's the book from the photo isn't
it mm-hmm and that's where I fell from
this guy because you're a dick
no I haven't checked these guys he died
as he lived
ah yes all right they're both dead you
check his pulse so you remember this
part at all the bookshelves do I raise
it do I take it oh is that how I get
through god I don't remember I'm sick
yeah you have the right idea
oh I got a hold it so you yeah it's
worth knowing you can't jump in this
game
oh I probably even go look farther to
the left I think
oh never mind you were good before that
there you go okay and then this one
comes over or what yeah but it's on the
crank right now so I take the crank
I need a crank handle yeah got it
a Crandall Crandall all right I
understand I think okay so I want to
[ __ ] get out of here ah goody check
my mitt so the main hall is to the left
to your yeah but first yeah before you
do that I would go through there there
is a big quest item I don't want it I'm
not I'm not messing with you you are no
it's one of the medallions god bless
everything what's that noise
I have this information this is the uni
[Music]
unicorn I mean I don't know what that is
Oh fiche double-double like yin yang
fish okay scorpion old piece of meat
what it looks like a chicken wing it's a
jar spilling water or something well
agree to disagree
fish scorp piece of meat it looks like a
drumstick okay with hair coming off it
alright I'm officially full boo map
oh there's a door in here should I go in
there it gets locked but you can try it
I hope it's locked okay good
I want to go home yeah so ooh that feels
so tasty I like the noise it's chunky
walk
Superchunk the texture of that knob was
delightful it's not my not my job not my
prob I'm going to the main hall to
polish my knob that's not as saying in a
non-sexual there is no other way got an
HDMI I got pulled out oh let me turn
this up take a look oh my god he made it
the rookie thought he looked familiar
he's just staring at that court door
second floor
he's side okay thanks Marvin I'm on it
just kind of smiling a little weird in
that I'd like to save I feel very
strongly about it
yeah you can also offload the medallions
here I only have one on me no you got
one oh yeah but there's an item box
right behind you
I'm gonna keep the gun or the pignoli
yeah her run is so weak
okay save Oh second I'm sorry go did you
get the medallion that's right above
that statue was that the lion medallion
I don't think so yes right yeah okay
never mind I thought so yeah I got one
more that's the lion oh yeah also the
door right that Marvin is facing is also
a spade door might that might be the
last one should I say first sure it
doesn't hurt doesn't it does no it only
affect your final grade really I mean
like historically in this series the
more saves you use the lower your grade
will be I love saving and I could you
imagine if I got graded on how often I
check the map holy [ __ ] no cuz that's
like season players do that as well
that might be the last Spade door
doesn't it you know not in this game
it'll show the red checkmark now you
still have one more one or two it won at
least one why is it so do you recognize
this it's the quest office I do so
that's a nice little shortcut as well
well don't be on welcome Leone so
there's really nothing else to do in
here though I knew cuz I redirect I
thought I did it well the safe isn't
that office but you don't know the
combination yet right okay so what
should I do now probably go where Marvin
had mentioned oh wait can you did you
open those cabinets behind you down
Bevin
yeah you did sorry probably do it Marvin
said he was saying go through the east
side of the second floor in the main
hall
second floor sorry got it
what was that it's like fragmenting is
there any way you weren't able to is
there anything you weren't able to pick
up on the east side first floor high
your app trying to be on the second
floor no I was talking about the first
floor
I like the press room bathroom no I
think you got everything right now okay
you didn't get anything in the main hall
apparently
oh right actually I think it's all the
way at the end of this right here Wow
I don't know what I could have missed in
here is this a new place Spade door yeah
it is
Carly Blair officer of the month the
lieutenant gave it to himself three
years in a row
oh good take this now yeah
welcome while at the home of the
pharmaceutical giant umbrella
corporation it's a vibrant and dynamic
city with a long rich history um I used
to be an art museum just a few blocks
from the police station is an orphanage
founded and run by the umbrella Corps
for the help of generous donations from
businesses and citizens alike building
is known for its stained glass window
interesting right all right I don't know
this dang it
nice try first try master of
lock-picking my but that was Jill not
Claire sorry that might have a blast
Spade door oh yeah there you go
oh yeah by selecting discard okay so
should I just discard it yeah can I do
that too like my gun do that I don't
know if they'll let you do it to your
gun but you can definitely do it to
almost anything all right I [ __ ] hate
those why is this hallway sucks so much
where am I have I ever been here before
I've never been in here now
all right well it sounds like there's a
murderer in here where should I go
this way or this way they both sound
awful I either way works honestly
Oh accent that's good my god
Mikey
Oh God
I'll go down the hallway first before
you go out the door I think hey it's my
key I don't think he made it huh wait oh
no he did my key
what a terrible way to go you know it's
kind of his fault he flew into the
[ __ ] building I'm sure he was
zombified Mike he was a good pilot all
right so I'm going outside now Yeah
right up until the time he faced planted
into an art museum
okay I'd be outside
hey Claire
we are look so dainty you don't you all
right somebody no creature I just yeah I
take it you don't have the key jeez
Claire give it a rest she's laying it on
a little thick here
that was him in the helicopter I put him
in the helicopter to keep dry
don't worry about me just get yourself
to safety
seriously they're getting too fast
please just go
we're gonna make
of us
turns around and runs into a zom he's
good
should I so they can't come through
correct
you got all right sorry preparing
mentally for what's about sick is the
game play loud for you as well I wrote
down maybe a tiny bit thank you you're
like the only gauge I have for audio
because I'm wearing my headphones are
connected directly to the ps4 so I can't
hear with what OBS ears so I need you to
tell me that thank you
mm-hmm it wasn't crazy ladders nice to
turn town oh [ __ ] that my dammit
that might have been a good window to
board I don't think you would have a
chance can I might want to book that Wow
honey boards you have to I only have one
on me but there's one in the other place
that I didn't pick up where the liquors
where I was warned about the liquors but
I did not take home I would board this
one up
this guy's probably still alive yeah
you've been here before by the way I
don't know if you recognize it in a
dream Oh
Elle 101 Owen every look yeah so now you
can get your knife back I think unless
he is still alive I love that it's
covered in blood now
[Music]
how do I know which knife I'm using I'd
like to use this knife uh there's an ee
over it yeah should I stab him again
mmm if you do with that knife you'll
break it
really I mean it you're closer obviously
he is like in there working on report
open your map you'll see where you are
this was like the first hallway you came
down remember so the dude you just heard
was the one who got cut off by at the
waist by the door
that's him oh there's not really
anything you doing there yet should I
shown yeah you'll be going through early
got em
well you want me to go in there then or
no no I guess you're fine okay do you
think that guy is dead yep
that one out all right so finish this
hallway or go in here go in there
how long we've been recording like 45
minutes
No oh I [ __ ] missed I agree I love
her commentary when I'm shooting them
yeah
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up there's a window in
that room that you could have boarded up
that but the one you brought it up is
still helpful to board up all right just
get up so I can shoot you Chumbawamba
action
you're never gonna keep me down all
right I think he's dead
oh what's that okay
so I can't board that up - not until you
get more boards so why don't I try and
do this place quickly so you tell me
what I need and I'm gonna run around
there's a lot in this room oh I'm almost
full my ending the main hall is pretty
close well what should I do
do that move the chair that way that's a
shortcut
that's a good shortcut all right I'm
officially full eight Hollister left
this is the door that you just barely
escaped through last time for Marvin
there this is your way back to the Great
Hall me
oh my little baby heart that was good
begin the episode wait yeah you haven't
gotten hurt you haven't gotten hurt this
episode at all
oh here's oh there you go cool all right
it's good that every item in here now I
would hope so um keep an herb I have a
full yeah yeah but the regular you ate
no you're fine without the green herb
yeah you're good I would go back to the
room years tune though there's a few
more things I think
it's this room yeah and there is a
zombie in here where is it I don't know
he sounds close
I think this one behind you as well no
way
stop
do do you hear that there's another one
in here
yeah there's something - I [ __ ] hear
another one I just don't know where he
is
oh no I'm [ __ ] panicking what should
i do what should I do
I'm leaving you're fine kill him nope
[Applause]
yeah this nice
what should shoot him yeah just shoot
him okay oh wait there's another one
right behind her - I know they're police
I know tonight I can't handle what I
can't no you know I can't okay that's
too many
I could route them I don't know that
they'll go through that door but they're
better off in there than they were in
the other room
let me ask you this what happens if I go
well the fire like tape shouldn't the
fire do this yeah that was I thought the
same thing
you're on fire you're dead oh my god
can I walk past them I think so are you
[ __ ] kidding me
make sure you yeah so if if you're not
facing them when they grab you you
automatically get hurt so what did I get
hurt no no no you're fine
you wouldn't you can't use your sight if
they grab you from behind you can't use
your knife
so they'll hurry you know
I don't one bullet I'm freaking out it's
alright go the Great Hall is through
this hallway I'm no actually oh [ __ ] no
no hold on horn okay calm down
I know I know what to do go through the
door to your right oh there's boards
there too nice
what's your what's your inventory
looking like yeah get those boards
I have nothing it's okay
get those boards and then back up to use
this door oh you can't even go that way
yet anyway I'm so [ __ ] like literally
if there's zombies I can't do anything
it's okay so this is telling about the
Ruby this is all you could skip this
okay I like I'm in no mood to read a
magazine yeah I know yeah all right
sweet now you can get another weapon
from the weapons Locker but first
there's other stuff in this room I have
a I don't have the book on me but I have
the book yeah should I give him the book
yeah
should I combine the arm in the book and
then put it on him yeah but you might as
well just leave the arm here for now
just so you don't take up space sorry
like on him I don't think you could
leave it there got it
I thought there were handgun rounds in
here too you're not dude what a bad bad
set a zombies they just wouldn't die all
right okay um so the main hall is right
across the hall to the left and then you
can go
you have enough gunpowder I would
actually say you could probably make
some hanging around so you want it to I
kind of want to because I literally have
no bullets I have nothing I can't
protect myself fair enough um and then I
would also say that might be an episode
um let's go to get the next weapon and
then call it an episode okay so so but
yeah like I would just to make sure we
don't die at the end the episode bring
those boards bring I would say bring it
a green herb and then combine to
gunpowder's cuz you have yeah you have a
lot of gunpowder well how am I gonna
bring anything back if I mean well the
two gun powers will just become handgun
rounds oh I see are you saying you might
not need the greener then
do I need this because I would take the
I would pack the cutting tool um yeah we
might run into something I would just
don't bring the green herb you're fine
with the full heal and then um what's
the fastest way to get there I'm trying
to think you open your mouth you know I
will oh oh yeah through the West office
okay cool which is right there and then
up to the safety deposit room to your
right
did you reload yes okay why I just did
not remember if you reloaded it's not
true always be reloaded that's what I
always say
you better be dead [ __ ] he's
twitching well yeah they just do that
sometimes it's pretty creepy okay cool
so you can go oh yeah also when you use
the keycard you lose the keycard so then
I'll free up another space um what am i
using it on all the way in the back so I
pick one no you just use it
hmm green ads grenade launcher is
capable of firing flame and acid rounds
should I might as well just load those
flame rounds in right now sweet you want
to go save in the main hall and call in
an epi that looks so cool just the way
that's hang it yeah well it's also you
probably noticed this by now but
anything you have equipped is also on
her so her extra hip pouches show up
once you would get those her extra night
her knife is there like she just had a
normal belt before you got those hit Rae
edition it's almost like a dead space II
kind of thing yeah feels very honest to
have her carry all this [ __ ] around all
right I'm gonna save sweet no deaths yet
hurt at all
I did no you didn't oh I didn't you
started off at a caution and no eye
contact but I stabbed people twice yeah
so you made good use your defensive
items sweetie so wait this will go up
our first episode will be the Saturday
right after launch on the 26th we might
put this up like you could do a double
feature it depends on how many we can
record we might yeah we might put this
up like the next Monday either way this
is episode 2 so as always everybody
thank you for joining us thanks for
being patient while we work out
technical stuff let us know in the
comments if things aren't right like if
the framerate is weird if you see like
stuff I'm recording these and changing
the bitrate each episode just based on
like what it looks like to me but I'm
mostly interesting what you guys think
if the game audio is too high or too low
let me know yeah and hopefully
everything's good in Portland it's
freezing here in New York yeah it's
rainy here
yeah it rains it was raining here a
little bit but it's snowed westeners
here but it's not that cold but it's
rainy almost like four or five days a
week I'd say
it's crazy yeah and then now as of this
episode people will have been able to
play the game so hopefully people are
enjoying it because I really like the
game yeah I'm hearing glowing reviews
although I'm not clicking on them that
I've heard wonderful things cool okay
sweet well thanks everybody for some LOL
if you have if you're not part of the
cannibal discord
joana our buddy Nathan usually puts it
in the YouTube comments one of the
usually one of the first comments and
there's a lot of fan art like the one we
from from our friend say GE earlier yeah
pardon me if I forgetting the name and
we had some and during our intro slide
earlier we had one from our friend David
Hart people do a lot of cool fan art you
probably seen us tweet it or put it on
Instagram or something but keep that
coming because that's awesome
and we'll prominently feature it
whenever you drop it in with honor yes
sweet all right we'll see you guys next
week
on Resident can evil remake to thank you
better keep those mouth sounds shuttered
right now oh my god